hi I'm Ryan cougar and welcome to scene
at the Academy the Black Panther what
kind of forever obviously the film was
dealing with grief and um
the idea of learning how to cope with
the loss and we we worked really hard to
make sure that thing was present
throughout the film
um in terms of film language what we
were communicating with the audience
um but in terms of what we were feeling
we were all you know we were all living
that process uh as as people and as and
as artists uh and as a collective it
didn't take a lot of uh of artificial to
have our have our Focus you know on the
topic and on the subject matter
um but we still had to go through the
work of you know making decisions on
like communicate you know what the
characters were feeling
um where we want the audience to feel
and also uh the the idea of um
of grieving being in like a necessary
part of life you know not just not just
a bad thing
um something that you have to have to
learn to live with and um and have to
make you know come to an understanding
of it on your own terms that's what the
film does with that a lot so for me as
far as the movie goes and the through
line of the death t'challa you know this
is a franchise that we lost our leader
we lost our King so this franchise could
have been over so for us to keep going
in memory of him is what we're honored
to do here
um it was incredible as an actress
that's what you are intent on doing is
using if you can some of those portions
those pains that Joy of your real life
if you can bring that to a character in
a realistic and a and a thoughtful way a
way that it helps it helps also in the
personal healing and I think that is
indeed what we went through as as actors
on the stage we had
um the hair the costume the the scenery
that that helped us it got us they got
us there that put us in the moment that
was a cohesive element for all of us but
also then we brought our own personal uh
feelings and and what we felt in the
loss of the moment to those scenes
very easy
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
for me you know basically Ruth Carter
she really led the charge for us it's in
this funeral scene the clothes were
absolutely where we started and
everything that we we did as far as the
hair goes is going into the tribal looks
and even taking them to a new level
because we have never seen any of our
tribes in the tribal look so just for us
was doing what we had done and the first
one but seeing everybody and mourning
and seeing everybody in white was really
the most powerful thing you're still
seeing all the elements of the hair
you're seeing locks you're seeing braids
you're seeing Afrocentric hair and so
that's what we portrayed throughout the
movie and in the scene the way that
people deal with grief is different for
everyone and
um we had a sudden loss and we also had
the opportunity with the funeral scene
to have if have a grieving period
between not only the story but between
us as crew members we had some place to
pour our grief into we had a story that
was crafted through grief by Ryan
coogler and
the opportunity to be able to do that
immediately following his passing was
incredible and very very heavy load to
to Bear but also a very cathartic
process when you see those tears those
were real tears that we felt for him
that we felt in the Lost in the real
missing and mourning of that person and
have the opportunity to use that in our
art is cathartic as Ruth said and it's
very powerful and healing there was a
huge mural on the side of a wall that
had been painted of Chadwick and once
you you know proceed it and then of
course it's cut and go back to go back
to your starting point you turned around
and you gazed at it you saw it for the
first time and it was just Divine and
perfect in that moment
um you just literally just open your
heart open your memories of this
wonderful human being actor leader
um
and and and go for it be there with one
another holding each other's hands I was
there you know walking along with shuri
who had uh a uh a great relationship
with Chadwick her brother sister
relationship on and off the screen so
um it was a very
um I think it was it was a very
moving moment for her
um so as a as her colleague as her
mother as her friend
um all of that in holding her up in me
and and being mindful of her and what
she's going through we
um we just carried that over into the
scene there's still being a very a very
wakandan ritual this is not a uh an
event where the whole world is invited
to it you know
um something that's that's that's
personal and cultural and someone into
it
um and a lot of that came from the
research there and obviously I trickles
through those apartments you know
um working with working with Ruth and
her Department working with
Camille and Joel uh Harlow
um and working with Hannah Baker and
Autumn durard aquapon you know we were
all kind of hauling hands
um and thinking about you know how we're
gonna present this and how it's gonna be
cohesive and feel like something that
has been happening in this place for
thousands and thousands of years this
idea of uh of not being the first Common
King and die there's a there's a process
that they go through
um you know who's in you know thinking
about who's holding the casket who's in
who's in which position
um what kind of shots are we doing are
we in handheld or are we in studio mall
you know we talked about all these
things and we would talk about them
together you know um it was also uh this
idea of of the procession of being
um somewhere between a morning thing and
a celebration you know
um kind of kind of threading that new
it's something that you're seeing in in
African cultures and also cultures of
the diaspora and Ruth knocked it out of
the park you know um with all white
Jabari costumes and all white Dora
costumes all white Queen Ramana and
Sherry
um the textures the different bee work
they had you know Artisans working from
all over the world to to contribute
um to make it feel like you were
watching something that I thought was
how I was supposed to be you know even
though we wanted to feel manufactured
that makes sense and for the makeup you
know there's a lot of Storytelling being
told in all of the makeup
um this idea that that t'challa was the
first king to reunite the five tribes of
wakanda you know you will see a lot of a
lot of um a lot of you know hand prints
white hand prints on a lot of the Jabari
in in five uh you know stripes on a lot
of people's faces you know um and it
brought back a lot of the dotting the
specific dotting that you're seeing on
shury's face that kind of through on
through our through her whole costume
um so it was a lot it was a lot of
intricate work um you know I'm really
happy that I that folks are being
recognized for it with all that we
wanted the audience to feel like they
were
you know that that was for them as well
you will be stripped of your rank as
general of wakanda's armies and your
status
you may
have given everything
let me die saving my country and dark
Throne that thing
allow me to make this right make it
right
I do not know if my daughter is alive or
dead abs
we are being
she raised a spear against her own
husband for wakanda where is her
treacherous husband now but in a place
where she can visit if she wished mine
it's with the ancestors I am queen of
the most powerful nation in the world
and my entire family is gone
have I not given everything
dress resplendently in that red and the
issue called sitting upon ishikolo
sitting upon the throne the throne that
my son had sat on
uh and was no longer on but now I have
to feel fill this seat
and
just
just you know rocking back and forth in
that you know in that moment of what it
means that he's gone with all of the
the the
Dora melange around you and the elders
around you and the tribes around you and
the people who depend on you just taking
in and just taking in all the the
different aspects of the room and what
it means and what is going on and being
open and available to to to Okoye and
what she's saying to me and
feeding that through my perspective as
wife and mother
um in this moment and feeding it through
my perspective of love and loss and
grief in this moment that was an
emotional scene also for all of us to be
in also be in the throne room and to
seeing Angela even if you watch her body
language and that you know you see her
when she first starts off her arms are
over the chair then she moves her arms
inside like even her physicality in it
is is the acting and the motion in it
that we get to see and again you get to
see her in the beautiful beautiful
costume that Ruth did and you see her in
her beautiful crown but you see her
strength there and you even see her
strength as her character and you've
seen like her pain of what she was going
through and what she was what where she
was headed and what you know even what
was happening in the movie this is a day
that we have prepared for that Ryan
coogler has you know
um told me countless times that this is
when you know so all of the military
factions come together because Okoye is
in front of tribal council with this
huge she's lost the princess you know
this is a big moment and when I look
towards Angela Bassett and I see her in
the red dress and she's sitting on the
throne
um we put the Dora melange behind her
that's where how Ryan staged the scene
and the composition of color of her red
dress and the door milage behind her as
an army this the highest ranking female
fighting force of wakanda standing
behind the ruler of wakanda's very
powerful
um and very
um female woman driven a powerful moment
for her she's sitting there so casually
with her arms crossed she's wearing this
um incredible
um
look for the queen
um you know I step outside of myself as
a costume designer and I take in the
composition of what I'm looking at and
she's she's adorned and she's wearing
the ishikolo the the Queens uh the
Queen's crown and Angela delivers the
performance the masterful performance of
a queen so what she says um that she's
that she's queen of this big powerful
place that's probably the most powerful
place in the world but but she doesn't
have any family and and that that that
was was a lot of the irony of our
situation you know that we had to we had
this big giant movie you know um that
that was considered to be you know
wildly successful in
um
and kind of like
you know um
a big moment for representation and what
the future of the industry could be but
we got the wind knocked out it was you
know when our when our when when the the
guy who was the face of that in the
backbone of it was was taken away you
know
um and so that was kind of how we felt
every day you know what I mean like we
got all this you know we got all this
this
money now and attention and and all this
you know all of this all of this these
great things you know
um but but the guy who we did it with is
not here anymore it's a very it's a very
strange feeling you know um and and I
thought Angela just kind of knocked that
out of the park you know in terms of
you know in terms of saying that you
know
um and that is that is like a universal
truth you know what I'm saying like what
good is you know what good is having
power what good is having strings if you
don't have anybody here to share with
you
[Music]
Lift Me Up
oh
hold me down
keep
me close
the closing scene is like when you see
Sherry on the beach and you can see the
waves and you see you see the wind in
her hair but it feels like when she's
laying the dress you know in the fire
it's almost like she's laying down all
her burdens and hopefully she's almost
gonna be like the Phoenix and she's
gonna rise and she did she rose out of
that fire and just laying those burdens
down and just letting them go and going
into her new life and who she is to her
community and who she is to wakanda
it was perfectly suited to the moment
um and and that moment being of a young
woman shuri who we see in flashbacks was
was so young and hopeful and full of
life and you know and as a little sister
a kid or brother and was brilliant and
that she's obviously now having
gone through a real a real
heart-wrenching life change and that's
and
all sound to have disappeared
to have gone away faded away in that
moment that she sits on the beach
except for just faint Whispers you know
of the Wind
uh uh it's like her listening for that
small that small still voice
um
you know that will soothe her comfort
her and that song is just very hopeful
Lift Me Up Hold Me Down keep me close
safe and sound
the significance of um of Lift Me Up
playing at the end of the film you know
it's really like uh I think
symbolic of the journey that sure he
goes on
um and she's a surrogate for us I think
she's a surrogate for the audience you
know
um
this idea of grappling with
um a profound loss that feels unfair
and and not having anywhere particularly
to put your anger you know I'm not
having anywhere really
um
to get answers for why you know
um and I think that that you know she's
she's struggling with with uh
a lot of things in in
finds herself a different person from
who she was before she lost the things
that she lost films in many ways are
coming of age as well
uh
not just like in terms of her maturing
but but
in terms of ways that life can transform
you you know so I think I think it's a
lullaby for me for for parents and
children you know but it's also it's
also something that you might
sing for somebody who's passed away you
know both the both the ends of the
spectrum you know
um
it works both ways for for me it's a
it's a song where I um
I think about a lot yeah
you know but it'll it'll always be uh
type of chat for me
at the same time
the the music of wakanda forever has
changed me as a filmmaker I have
experienced music on this film
differently than I have experienced on
any other film I've ever done and lift
me up uh is a lullaby that speaks so
much to the heart
um I feel like it was written from the
heart it was composed from the heart
um this scene uh with Sheree who has
given up so much she's has had so much
loss she lost her brother in real life
and in cinema life and then she loses
her Cinema mother and uh the song
um you know it's just just watching the
scene
um that you just showed just brings
tears to you because we had so much joy
in Panther one experiencing it with
Chadwick and and seeing the sister
brother relationship play out you know
so so well and then we all suffered the
loss of our brother and that song is
um a culmination of our emotions